all right even though I'm in Las Vegas
Nevada today for the mass towards made
perfect conference we're not taking a
break from hatred mail hatred mail
persists even during remote broadcasts
and if you're not familiar with hatred
mail hatred mail is when a professional
voice-over artist does interpretive
readings of the hate mail that I get
here's a little bit more about what this
is the right of the people to keep and
bear hates shall not be infringed
Patriot man written by Patriots who hate
David Pakman because America and because
freedom this week's hatred mail has
something that we have never ever seen
before which is a multilingual Patriot
mail we've seen things that sound like
other languages because of poor spelling
and grammar in hatred mail before but
we've never actually seen that I can
remember an actual hatred mail that is
clearly including other languages and I
think that that's all that I'll say
about this week's let's take a listen to
it and see if we can make heads or tails
out of it David Pakman so Silesia gran
puta de mierda and a sucker to boot a
good commie is a dead one your race
explanation is full of logical fallacies
between Raquel mad cow mr. and mrs.
deliverance Matthews and Humpty Dumpty
you're right up there with a lying phony
fake never report the truth news out
there one more cover-up for the corrupt
Democrat party I would translate what is
being said here in some kind of
combination of Spanish and Italian
but translated to English it would get
our broadcast affiliates in trouble so
I'm not going to do that I am interested
though they they refer to other media
people so I know Raquel mad-cow is
clearly Rachel Maddow
mr. and mrs. deliverance I have no idea
who that is Matthews I assume means
Chris Matthews on MSNBC and Humpty
Dumpty I also have no idea
who that is so I don't know what the
media diet is of this hatred but what I
can tell you is that if you don't like
that perspective if you actually think
that independent media like the David
Pakman show is worth supporting there is
a coupon code which is a big middle
finger to the hatreds and that coupon
code is hatred for tea
when you go to david pakman.com slash
membership and you type in the coupon
code hey tree @ 4 th atri ot 4 0 you
save 40% and hatred cries and i think
that that's something that a lot of
people like and shockingly I only
mentioned that coupon code once a week
when we do hatred mail and it is our
most used coupon code period more people
are signing up with that coupon code so
clearly there's something that resonates
with our audience about giving a
proverbial middle finger to the hatred
so congratulations and thank you to
everybody who's using that code